welcome to the pie snip tools tutorial
I'm so PI snip tools is an open source
library we originally created it for
reading bed files but now it's expanding
I think it'd be useful for other kinds
of matrix data I'm Carl Katie I'm
microsoft research in the genomics
research group and i'll also be giving
some background about what we do to help
me get an idea of who you are I'd love a
show of hands so who works with genomic
files like the plink bed files and
phenotype files okay just be really well
even if you might it'll be very relevant
to you who uses numpy arrays but with
like some more pandas like features good
you can answer more than affirmatively
to more than one by the way interested
in kind of fast sets of integers on
ranges good that one actually surprises
me it's cool we'd like just to learn a
bit more about genomics from a Python
perspective good we'll be covering that
dual degree interested in particular the
fast lem program for doing genome-wide
Association studies okay interested in
just an example of a what I hope is a
nice python library and its design good
and if we have time interested in one
opinion about what's good and bad about
Python from someone who's been doing
scientific programming and other
languages for 19 years now maybe longer
okay I had the instructions for to it
how to install their live examples and
an eye Python notebook that you can
download you can find it by downloading
a zip file either from that tinyurl or
you can search the PI snip tools
documentation and you can see the zip
file but it's okay if you don't
do that now I'm going to run the note
the ipython notebook live but if you can
either do it yourself also or you can
just watch it'll work out fine either
way so let me give a little bit of
background on where I'm coming from I'm
in the genomics research group of
Microsoft Research we were very recently
renamed from the e science research
group before that we spun out of the
machine learning and applied statistics
research group considering that history
we've been creating an applying decision
theory and machine learning for 20 years
I think one of our biggest things was
out of our groups our group spun out a
product group the spam filter group
which was one of the first spam filters
commercial spam filters and is still the
provider of spam filters for hotmail
outlook and Exchange language-wise we
used to use C++ for our things that
needed to be really fast and VB for you
eyes then we switched to c sharp for
both for the less and we'd make our C
sharp faster by using MKL matrix
libraries the past three years we've
been using Python we still use a version
of the MKL library that we get from
anaconda and we also write a little bits
of c++ code to make things faster where
we see the need currently most of our
work is on creating new analysis tools
typically are what we produce is open
source and for biology and we've got
papers on the genome-wide Association
studies and other topics in journals
such as science and nature also it's
being part of Microsoft we advise and
help Microsoft product groups especially
with respect to how we use Python or
scientific programming or issues like
that and this is work done with a wide
variety of collaborators and you can see
their names down there my background is
I have degrees in computer science and
machine learning I
came to Microsoft is an Internet
programmer for a product group but then
19 years ago transferred to research and
have been doing scientific programming
there ever since and a plan for the
morning we've done the intro and we're
on the plan we'll look at this is the
equivalent number of PowerPoint slides
so we'll look at a snip reader which was
it is an exemplar of the pie snip tools
and that'll be about thirty two slides
and they are the equivalent in the
ipython notebook to understand its
design and features then we'll have six
slides on PST reader which generalizes
snip reader to any matrix any numeric
matrix we'll look at another particular
kind of PST reader called Colonel reader
will look at those integer sets of four
slides then toward the end we'll see a
fast lamb and we'll talk about what it
is and how it uses PI snip tools to find
genome-wide associations if we have time
you can have four slides on my opinion
about why python is both a wonderful and
a terrible language there'll be one
slide in conclusion and we're a small
group so feel free to ask questions so
first let me give you an introduction to
genetic data if you had it the sample
data that comes in the zip file I can
look at now or later if you look at it
it just has files like all bed album and
all dot fam and they're just they're
just text files not a point
okay good the most interesting file is
yeah this will call it this is the bed
format from the blink consortium I guess
so the most interesting file in there is
the bed file it has columns and rows say
1.5 million columns each one represents
a DNA position 1.5 million DNA positions
that we call snips places where DNA is
known to vary between people and then we
might have the data for say 5,000 people
and that would be the row zero to five
thousand at any intersection we have the
nucleotides the a this see the tea or
the g-value that person zero has at DNA
location 0 snip location 0 in this case
I've said this person has a a you can
see that for this first snip most people
have a a one for mom one letter comes
from dad some people have 80 and a few
people might have TT there's a another
file that goes along with this if you're
reading a bed format it's the bin file
it contains the names of all the DNA
locations which are just a string and it
has some additional information it'll
have the chromosome that DNA location
snip location appears on 02 chromosome
22 and it has two other numbers which I
didn't make up here measuring genetic
distance where the DNA location is along
the DNA one thing that's a little
peculiar about this kind of genomic data
is individuals identified with an ID
that's not unusual but they're
identified with a two part ID the first
parts called the family ID and the
second part is called sometimes called
the case ID and together the two of them
provide a unique identifier so let's a
couple
think things here a lot of genomic work
isn't from databases it's just from
these plain files the matrix data may be
too big for a computer's memory so when
we just have these four letters plus
missing then we only have four values
and this file format compresses that to
two bits even a tube it's 1.5 million
DNA locations by 5,000 people is almost
two gig and if we expand this out to be
a real number which we need to do for a
lot of our learning and analysis that
becomes eight bits of full floating
point number and this will become 56 gig
and you can imagine this is 5,000 people
what happens when we have 10,000 people
20,000 people now we're talking a
hundred gig 200 gig of memory an
important principle that we can kind of
pick from the bed format is that
compared to the size of the this the
main data the information about
individuals and about snips is very
small five thousand times smaller a
million times smaller so we really don't
well we'll see the consequence of that
also we can look at this and say you
ought to be able to read data from this
file access data randomly it would be
crazy to read it all in if all you need
is a particular row or set of rows and
columns and this is something I hadn't
really thought of usually you think of
tabular data which this kind of follows
of just being the center part but here
we have this auxiliary data the bin file
data with genetic information in
chromosome data that's kind of
interesting and I think it's useful in
other contexts to have kind of small
amounts of data that go along with
either the roads are the columns so the
first thing this library has to do is be
able to read these bed files
so here we have a ipython notebook first
cell died already ran just sets up some
things and two we want a we call it the
format is the the readers are called
snip readers but there's a different
snip reader for each file format that
you're reading off disk so the bed snip
reader you say import bed and then give
the name of the file that will return
the snip reader and then we can print
the snip reader so let's see what that
looks like and we do that we get the
name of the reader all dot bad what's
interesting here what's important here
is that we haven't actually read any
data at all so far we can't ask about
the number of I IDs individuals or snip
IDs which is the columns we can ask for
a list of the individual ideas and we
can ask for a list of the snip IDs if
you do that we see in this the synthetic
data set so that we don't intrude on
anybody's genetic privacy so in this
synthetic data set we have 500
individuals 5,000 snips the first three
I IDs are here you can see they have the
two part the family in the case and then
here's a list of the snips to answer
these queries we have read a little bit
of data from the file but we still
haven't read the main matrix file so
that's another key we could assume that
we can get information about the labels
that we have on the rows and columns and
there and the properties on the rows and
columns basically for free and it's only
the main data that we want to avoid
reading for now finally when we do want
to read the data there's a command on
any snip reader called read the result
of that is a snip data a snip data is
also a snip reader but it has an
additional field so we can see it's a
snip reader because after we create it
we can print it it's the snip data made
from
reading a bed file on this file we can
ask these about these same properties
they match up as they did before as I
said it has this in addition has this
Val attribute and we print the first
seven of that we see the actual numbers
from the data this is a regular numpy
array a floating numpy array and that
means you can take the dot Val and do
things like ask what are the mean of the
values and here the mean is so 1.47 if
all you want is to read data from an
umpire ray you don't have to do things
in the steps I just showed you can put
it all together you can create the bed
give the file say to read look at the
Val and then do whatever else you want
with it you'll get the same answer you
might think that's kind of crazy we'll
talk about why we're doing it in three
steps instead of one in just a second
you can also create the in-memory snip
data object from scratch you don't have
to necessarily get it by reading a snip
reader so here we imported Atta and to
create it from scratch you give it the I
IDs which are pairs of strings the SIDS
which are strings and then the the Val
which is something can be converted to
floats and then we can take the point a
so let's go back to the PowerPoint
so in summary with respect to bed files
the bed is the snip reader for the bed
format you can see I I diid count SI d
count before reading any snip data no
snip data is read read until you say
read the result of reading is a snip
data object which has a valla attribute
and you can create snip data objects
from scratch and here you can see kind
of a way to look at the data that's
involved in a in a snip data and any
snip reader is the same except it
wouldn't have the dot Val so you're
looking at I going man off all you
wanted to do was read a bed file why did
we have to go through three steps why
didn't you just say I don't know read
bed or something wouldn't even need an
object there's a payoff the reason we do
it in three steps is because it
facilitates reading subsets of the data
and also reordering the data when we
want the rows or columns in a different
order and let's look at the notebook to
see how that works so suppose we only
want the data for one column which is a
snip we create a snip reader for reading
bed files and then we create a new snip
reader that's our old snip reader with
with array indexing now if you're this
is the same array indexing that numpy
arrays use recall that everything before
the comma tells what rose you want and
everything after the column tells what
columns you want a colon by itself means
the whole thing so we want all the rows
and a zero means we want a 0th column so
now we have a new snip reader called
snip zero reader let's print out what
snip zero reader is its I ID count it's
it's SI d count and then what s IDs it
has so when we print out we just do a
print on
we can see that it's kind of got a
readable name it can remind us what it
is and where it came from it still has
the hundred cases I IDs that we expected
before but now instead of five thousand
columns it only has one column and
here's the label for that one column the
s ID so here's an interesting question
we've said we wanted to read just one
column what happens to our original snip
reader called snip reader the answer is
it's unchanged now we have two things
for reading from this file one is set up
to read all the data and the second one
is set up to read only one column to
actually read we say snip 0 reader read
and that gives us snip 0 data we can
print that out we can look at its
dimensions and we can look at some of
its values so we saw the name before 500
x 1 and then here's the first 10 values
from from this column what's the bed
reader is smart because we only asked
for one column that's that's all at red
so it didn't have to load everything
else into memory here's so this should
be straightforward suppose we want the
iid it index position we want basically
the column with index 9 i'm sorry the
row with index 9 how would we do that
well in one line we can give the file we
can say we want row nine we can say we
want all the columns we can read it and
print the value and there we how we read
just one one row in some ways well okay
so now we always we want the first five
columns and the first five rows very
straightforward the notation in Python
for all the whatever is up to but not
including five so 0 through 4
is colon and then the number you want to
stop on so colon 5 colon 5 specifies is
the range of rows and columns we read
and print out and we see our dimensions
are five we can ask this object what are
the names of your column oh sorry rose
the IDS it shows us those we can say
what are the names of your columns the
snips it gives us those and we can ask
for all its data because we did the read
and we see all the numbers there so the
indexing of one reader to create a new
reader to say that you only want to read
a subset stacks you can keep doing it so
here's an extreme example snip reader a
is a bed reader for all bed we tell that
that we want to create a new reader be
that's a butt up but the first 250
columns then from be we want to create a
third reader which is reader be but the
first 10 rows I IDs and then finally
from d we want to take the reader that
we've got from C and take every other
row and every other column the notation
for every other python is colon colon 2
so let's print this fourth reader and
look at its dimensions so we print it
and it actually remembers all the ways
that we got to it we ask its dimensions
it's 5 by rose by 125 columns we can
again look at the the I IDs that label
each row you can see you go now 0 2 4 6
8 because we did the every other and
this last step was we did it we did a
read and printed the first 10 values and
you can see them there
yeah the readers aren't even views the
readers are a promise that if you ask it
to read it will be able to read but it
doesn't pull any data or make any data
accessible to you until you say dot read
yes you can think of it as a lazy
evaluation we'll see how to write in a
few soon you can do all kinds of all the
fancy indexing that numpy supports pison
of tools supports almost to its credit
it actually supports some things that
numpy arrays don't support numpy arrays
sometimes none pie raves will get mad at
you if you try to do things on rows and
columns at the same time and in PI snoop
till she you're always allowed to do
that oh I don't maybe I forgot to
mention something important here this
fourth reader it only ever went to disk
for those final values that it needed it
didn't go through all four steps and
read things and throw it away and read
things and throw it away and read things
and throw it away it's compressed all
four steps down into one step and read
only the final values that were needed
ok back to fancy arrays instead of a
single index for the row or the colon or
the colon colon 2 you can give a list of
indexes so that's a way that you can you
can use this to reorder your rows so
here we're saying we want rose 4 3 2 1
and 0 with a colon do a read and it'll
die sleep now you have this new snip
data object and the new snip data object
knows that its names for its rose or cid
for p0 3 2 1 and 0 so the labels will
always track the data you don't have to
worry about them getting out of sync we
can take this snip data
and use a boolean selection another
thing you'll see on numpy arrays and we
can say we don't want the first thing we
do want the second we do want the third
we don't want the fourth we do want the
fifth these are which rose we want and
we want all the columns so we took a
snip data array now we've got this thing
I call it 4 3 2 1 B we can print it out
it turned internally the name instead of
having the bully ins turned it to
indexes and you can look at the 2i IDs
we've now asked for so here's a question
this thing we just did a we just did
this boolean indexing on a snip data so
this thing that it produced can does it
have a dot Val attribute or not well
let's have Python tell us and the answer
is no if you take a snip dated and you
select use indexing just to create a new
reader that's a reader but no data
actually gets read until you say read
again say that again every time well
we'll see it in a moment if but the snip
data did have the data the thing we're
reading from does have all the data in
memory not on disk so you might think
well it seems inefficient to read from
it again there is a way to tell it when
you do the read that it's okay to create
a view that is to share memory so if we
do the read now we have snip data for 3
2 1 B and look at the value we get just
the final two rows we asked for by way
of review yeah
yeah the reed is what made the data go
into memory by saying view okay you're
telling it that it's okay if this new
data that you've created shares memory
with the thing that it read from yes and
it doesn't guarantee that it will share
memory pythons very opaque about when it
will actually have two arrays that share
memory and when they're separate from
each other so you don't really know for
sure finally negative indexing by way of
review in Python slicing notation you
have a start a stop and a step a
negative start means to count from the
end a negative stop means count from the
end a negative step means count
backwards we do support this indexing in
numpy arrays a minus one means the last
item in an array minus two means the
second to last I forgot to implement
this I plan to implement it soon sorry
about that you can enlists can also have
negatives and that's not implemented
either but it does work for slicing so
here is how you'd say I want the last
ten rows I want a reader that will read
the last ten rows so this is normal
Python notation on top of these new
things the snip reader so looking at how
we do the sub setting we can use
indexing on a reader to specify a new
reader for just the subset of the data
indexing is also useful for your
reordering rows and columns the ids and
SIDS using indexing to create a subset
reader doesn't change the original
reader every read will give us fresh
data unless we save you okay in which
case it's allowed to share data if it
wants to
and subsets of subsets of subsets
indexing on top of indexing all that's
fine the read will only read the final
data to the degree that that's practical
for it so I promised that we would have
access to some pandas like features and
I haven't actually shown any so far so
let me demonstrate that first a few more
options on read we saw you okay you can
also when you read data you can tell it
what order you want whether you want
your matrix laid out in fortran order or
c order that's important sometimes when
you need your data to be able to be read
fast and it also supports 8-bit floats
which is the default or 32-bit float
sometimes called singles and the option
for that is to set this D type argument
so let me show flags is the numba array
method that shows you the properties of
an umpire ray so after we do this read
we can see that by default things are in
fortran order and well that's the most
relevant thing here but if we ask for
things in c order and float 32 oh we
asked to get to create an array that's a
single instead of a double that's true
and and here we see that we can that
things are in c order also we saw
earlier on that there was this
additional information for every for
every snip DNA location called so to get
to that it's a property an attribute
called posts for position
we just look at it again you can get
this without having to read all the data
yeah there's no limit the question is
how much data can a reader read yeah it
depends on your computer so this laptop
is very small and I made sure all my
examples would fit in it but my work
machine has 48 gig and it can certainly
go that big it can be bigger than the
indexing the rows and columns can have
more than two billion entries I think
I'm not absolutely sure that but
gigabytes and gigabytes if you have the
memory that's correct so a lot of the
out yes so a lot of genomics algorithms
maybe it's okay to process what will
actually see an example this if we want
to find how related all 5,000 people are
to all other 5,000 people and we would
do that by doing some dot product of
their 1.5 million DNA locations there's
a very straightforward way of doing that
in batches you don't need to read all
the data at once you can read one
person's data at a time or one snip at a
time or 5,000 and this facilitates that
and in fact your algorithms can have an
option if they're using these readers to
tote to start blocking the data and only
read the sections that they need at a
time yes
so oh yeah so I promised so here's the
closest we get to having pandas like
features since we have this attribute
position that says what are what
chromosome each DNA location is on and
we can access it without reading all of
this giant snip data we can do things
like say that we only want to read the
data for everybody at only their
chromosome 5 data so first let's take a
look at that position attribute and say
that we want the data for all the people
the rose but only the first column and
that gives us just the chromosome number
now we can say tell us this is that same
expression tell us where that's equal
equal 5 this is just an umpire ray thing
this isn't anything I created yet so
just a normal umpire ray when you've set
it equal to a single value it returns a
boolean array telling you on each
element whether it's equal to 5 or not
so the first ones are all false and the
last ones are true now we can take this
array of bools and use it to index are
our columns and that gives us a reader
that will only read chromosome 5 and we
can actually do the read and if we do
the read and then ask what's the
position data for the thing that we've
read everything now is just chromosome 5
so we've created so we've selected just
the things that we wanted the columns
that we wanted and in one line we could
do that all in one line so here we've
read just chromosome 5 for everybody and
print it out the value likewise suppose
you only want to do read the individuals
or the rows for that you have the name
for basically you want to do a read by
name instead of by index value way to do
that is to create a list
the names that you want and then there's
a function called iid to index which
will take a a a row of a list of I IDs
and return the index value so here's
three people I put it through this and
it gives me back an array of the indexes
values for these three people and now we
can use that array and we've created a
reader that will only read data for
those three people and we can do that in
one line of course so here's the reader
and we've asked what people do you read
and it only reads the data for these
three rows and we can do both things we
can read just chromosome 5 for the three
people of interest and say find the mean
value do the actual read and then
compute the mean using Empire rays so to
review the additional methods and
attributes we can return things in
either for trainer see order which is
important for efficiency we can return
either doubles which is the default or
singles maybe we don't need the higher
precision we want to save memory every
snip reader has a position attribute
which is an attribute on the columns
that it has genetic info it's available
before we do any reads and then we can
whoops we can use iid to index and s ID
to index to turn names into indexes and
then we can do so that's basically as
close as we come to pandas where we can
do things by name and by x value to get
the Rose that we want in columns there
was a question about how do we write
data and you've also you've only seen me
demonstrating this on one kind of file
format the bed format so let's take a
look at that
so in genomics there's another very
common data set with a rather weird name
people if you look in the documentation
it's the plink alternative alternative
phenotype file it's just the text file
here's the what it looks like if you
just open it up it's white to white
space delimited it's got the family ID
in the case ID so together these are the
I ID and then there'll be multiple
columns at least one I guess here
there's just one and this is the value
of something that you measure in
genomics this might be something like
body mass index it could be a boolean
about whether or not somebody has a
disease pretty much anything like that
and for this format we've got a
different reader called fino and it
works just like bed except it knows how
to read from this format so we fino for
this file we can print it out and we can
ask for its attributes so when we print
it out it reminds us what it is and its
attributes are it has data for 500 I IDs
and only one it's calling it an SSID
better to think of this as a column
because it's not it's not really a snip
now it's just some other variable we can
ask what the list of column names are s
ID and it says it's fee no one and it's
not really meaningful if we're measuring
body mass index to say what's the
genetic what chromosome is the body mass
index on so it fills in that attribute
just with not a number values and if we
want it to read from the file we can
read from it and you're just printing
out the first 10 values so that's an
example of reading from a second file
format and now that we have to file
formats we might want to read from one
and write to another so we create a bed
reader for reading the first 10 values
from our bed file and then we'll say
fino trite so
every one of these snip reader classes
like fino in bed that know how to read
data also have a right method static
right method and the syntax is the name
of the file and then you give them a
snip data to write and if we do that we
can check the file exists we can also
convert this subset of the bed file and
create a new bed file when you write a
bed file you actually get a bed of BIM
and a fam that works we can create data
on the fly so we created our own snip
data like we saw before and then we used
wrote it into bed format and that's all
straightforward there's also two
additional snip readers that are handy
one is called snip npz it uses the
Python matrix num num PI R a matrix
format it creates very small and fast to
write and fast to read files so it's
sometimes the case that you'll you'll
want to write to npz just because it's
so you had a text file you might want to
read it in and then write it out if
you're having to read it over and over
again because the NPC format would be
faster hdf5 is a more general purpose a
file format that can do by can store
binary raise and we have a flavor of
that you can write to and read from the
nice thing about hdf5 is like the bed
format it supports low memory access of
rows and columns some of the other
formats like phenotype you can access
things in random access but underneath
the covers it really just loads
everything into memory because it
doesn't know any better way to read
those text files
so in summary methods like bed and fino
and snip npz and snip hdf5 all have
right methods snip data is our in-memory
format it doesn't have a right method
and snip reader when you do some
indexing that doesn't have a right
method and just to remind you only snip
data has the value attribute yeah yes it
never updates in place and I mean if you
wrote over it would but it doesn't
support that now I could imagine an
extension that did that it would look
like snip data but instead of what when
you wrote it would write it all the way
through but that's not the way it works
now yeah this biology data we tend
especially if we're going to do big
matrix operations like I can value
decomposition or whatever they 10 things
have to all be in at least big chunks
need to be in memory yeah and then we
might write back over what we had before
so here's a question so you do have this
genomics data but you want to use it
with somebody else's library not my
library like you just want to use some
SCA learn or some other libraries just
generic array libraries let's see how
snip hi tools mix that straightforward
so one of the most common things you
have to do is you have one data set that
has everybody listed in one order the
bed file say and you have another data
set that is everybody listed in a
different order but if you're going to
put this into a numpy method for say do
a linear regression or any of the
learning things it needs the two arrays
to have people to have the rows in the
same order so
in this example we read all the bed data
but our phenotype data pretend we have
only half the people and they're in
backwards order so that's what we're
simulating here so our bed reader has
knows about 500 people are phenotype
reader only knows about 250 and the bed
reader they go 0 1 2 3 4 5 and our
phenotype reader they're in backwards
order so how can we call some other some
kind of machine learning tool if our two
arrays are going to be half the data in
different order and the answer is
there's a utility called intersect apply
you give it a list of snip readers our
snip reader phenotype reader and it
returns new snip readers that still
haven't read any data but where the IEDs
will be intersected and in the same
order so i just asked it to verify that
the ID lists from both of these new
readers are the same and it's the deed
they are and then we can read them and
here's our data from bed and here's our
data from phenotype so let's see how to
use this in numpy is built in linear one
of its built-in linear regression
methods all we do is take say dot Val
that will give the kind of dependent
variables that sorry independent
variables that linear that the built-in
linear regression expects and then we
say dot Val and that gives its the
dependent variable it outputs a bunch of
things but the first thing it outputs is
the weight that you that it thinks you
should put on each feature case each
snip value and we can actually see how
well this model fits the data that we
train did on by multiplying the snip
data with a dot product times these
weights and then just doing a plot and
we can see that a test on train we're
doing great or
predicting it we're just we're just
nailing it of course tests on train is
usually a bad idea we really want to see
is how well we do on new data so suppose
we have the second phenotype reader and
it's going to read the other half of the
individuals we again put it through
intersect apply with the bed reader and
now we have the snip reader for the bed
for the genetic data and the our feature
now all lined up we can read them we can
take the weights from before and do the
dot product on this new data and then we
can plot the new the true values on this
unseen data and the predicted values and
now we see that linear regression turns
out to be a really bad idea if you have
5000 variables and only 250 cases I
think there's one more section specific
to genetic data and then we'll look at
broader topics so on this section we saw
that intersect apply can intersect and
reorder readers by iid it works before
reading this nip data from disks so it
can be very efficient I didn't show this
but it also works with none I works with
any number of snip readers you can pass
in a nun and you'll just get a nun back
also it can work with non snip readers
if you want to you can just give it a
tuple of an iid list and a numpy array
of values and it'll return a new iid
list and a new num PI array so that's
how you can work with other kinds of
data it's fine to do this step where you
kind of reconcile your data see dream
say you're the thing you're predicting
with your your main data your features
say and your target and then you can do
other things like cross-validation and
all that with indexing and you still
never have to read until the last minute
and it's we've seen how it
fault with other tools I tried to come
up with a question that would motivate
this small section all I came up with
was hey how do you do standardization
and kernels so this is a small section
really only of interest to genomics
so in genomics movie a it's basically a
kind of feature cleaning that we do in
genomics you have all these snips their
value zero one or two you don't want one
that has lots of tues to have
automatically more weight than one that
just has values near zero so what we
commonly do is go through and find the
mean and standard deviation of each of
these snips which are features and we
make them have zero mean and standard
deviation 1 by multiplying and adding
two numbers to each one that's called
unit standardization we can do that in
one step there's other kinds of
standardization like beta standardized
so we've defined a bunch of those
another thing that's interesting to do
is we off we almost always want to find
how related like 5,000 or 10,000 people
are to everyone else that's such an
important thing that we it's got a
built-in method called read Colonel
Reade colonel takes the standardized er
the reason it does that is because read
colonel can work on a reader you don't
have to load your data into memory to
create this this kernel let rip that
finds the matrix that of how related
everybody is to everybody else and as I
alluded to before this is one case where
we have a block size argument so you can
actually do this calculation 20,000
50,000 people related to each other and
you can do it in very low memory and it
will work yeah
so standardization only works on sniff
data so you have to do a read before you
standardize it works in place and that's
for efficiency so you have this dot Val
array when you standardize it actually
changes it also will return well you can
see that there are other standardized
errs that are handy whoops kernels read
colonel will return a kernel data
something that we haven't a data type we
haven't really talked about but you can
know it has a dot Val property and it
does the snip reading itself when you
don't want to it requires you to give it
a standardized ER if you don't really
want to standardize you just say could
you say identity standard dieser and
that's the one that does nothing ok so
those who are interested in more of the
genomics here's the generalization of
snip reader it's called PST reader and
it works on more kinds of matrix data so
as before the values we're dealing with
are still going to be reals either
single or double but now our row are
called row instead of iid and they don't
have to be two strings they don't even
have to be strings it can be any number
of things numbers strings or whatever
likewise columns don't have to be
identified with one string you can
identify it with any type you want and
it can have whatever with you want
before we had genetic properties up here
now you can have any number of those
properties they all have to have the
same type that it can be any type you
want and we didn't have any notion of
properties on the column properties we
didn't have any notion of column
properties sorry real properties before
so now we can have road properties and
in fact a snip reader is a PST reader so
anywhere before where you set iid you
can also say row and oops and kind of as
you'd expect where we had row count iid
count you can now say row count in
general iid to index you now say wrote
index
and that's our generalization to any
other data types that still has to kind
of fit this paradigm so let's see an
example of that so every snip reader is
a PST reader so we prove that by reading
it in and then asking for row count and
column count instead of iid count and
sidd count column property you can also
create a PST data on the fly from
scratch so now our rows instead of being
two strings or just one string our
columns or strings or values and we've
created something new a row property in
this case each row has the capital
letter of its index is its real property
and we can do all the things you'd
expect we can say we want a reader of
this data that selects all the rows
where the index is less than C
alphabetically and we can and where we
want the columns for Z and the column
for Y and we can do that all in one step
and it gives us a reader and if we read
that then we've got our data read and
all turned around the way we wanted and
we can even look for the properties and
the rows we just read and I didn't
define a column property in that on the
fly data structure so if you don't
define when it gives one with zero with
so it's defined it just doesn't happen
he doesn't have any width and we've got
two new readers pstn PZ and P st hdf5
and they work just the way you would
expect I would hope so taking that in
memory thing we had before we say dot
right we write it we can read it back in
we can write at hdf5 we can read that
back in we can look at the values from
the things we've been reading and
writing back in and they all match up as
we'd expect
I snip tools I just needed some initials
to identify it so when choosing these
formats the NP z is good because i think
it's the fastest binary format for a
raise in Python for reading at writing
hdf5 is okay for speed and size and it
allows low memory random access it's
also readable by other programs if they
can understand your schema so these are
almost the only PST readers that I've
created but if you have your own data
formats one difference between this way
of doing things in pandas or even numpy
is that you can it's extensible it
doesn't dictate a format you have you
take the format's that you already have
and you write a reader and once you have
that reader you can do all these other
tricks and writing a reader is
straightforward in the case where it's
okay to load all the memory all the data
into memory obviously if you need to be
able to access rows and columns and kind
of random order and low memory that's
going to take some coding that's
specific to whatever file format you
have we've done it for hdf5 in bed if
you have another file format you have to
work that out one slide on colonel
reader colonel reader is just what you'd
expect for representing this person to
person information that we see in
genomics so there's two flavors of it
one if the rows and column names are
just happened to be exactly the same it
will note that or they can be different
what's fun and the program's when using
this before i had this i had to write my
programs so they only accepted colonel
data kernels this represent this
relationship between people two people
in one format either they'd be on file
or they would be in memory
now i can write my program so it doesn't
care whether it's in memory or on file
or what's kind of cool is you can
there's even a kernel reader called snip
colonel it takes a snip reader and on
the fly will create the colonel that's
requested but only when it's requested
so that's a way to get a very low memory
and also some algorithms know how to
work with kind of implicit kernels and
they can look at this and be optimized
for that path I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a bit here's a
summary of all the formats we had PST
reader snip reader and Colonel reader
these are all apps trapped you don't
actually create a class with these names
but under PST reader we have PST data NP
z and hdf5 under snip reader we had all
these there's a few others I didn't talk
about and under criminal reader there's
these and it's easy to create more just
do the little bit of work to create a
reader and then you have access to all
the other features okay changing top
yeah
all the readers give you the syntax to
pull out just the number array that you
really want at the last possible minute
yes you have to make sure that you have
a reader that can read your data format
in random access the appropriate way so
I have that for my genomics data my bed
file you need to make a reader for your
like web page features or whatever it is
yeah so if you have a file format and or
if you could create it in memory and
then just write to PST and Pizzi or hdf5
that would work but you probably do have
to create one reader that gives you
random access to your data and then
after that you can use the rest of the
tools to pull things in parts and i
should say this is evolved I mean
obviously we started out with just a bed
reader and the bed reader didn't work
for us when we needed to apply the same
algorithms to phenotype data and then we
wanted to create some stuff in memory
and then we were running on a cluster
and the file format for the phenotype
reader was too slow so we wanted to cash
it we kept having a special case it's
special case it with this you write your
program so they only have to know about
one format and that's up to the and then
the caller has freedom to provide
whatever data is is sensible for that
run of in-memory on disk computer at the
last minute whatever okay this is only a
few slides but I think it's kind of fun
it would be the rude question to ask me
why would I think it's a good idea to
create another data structure for sets
and hopefully I can show that and
justify it
so here's the kind of problem that I see
all the time and I actually sell
problems like this not just with
genomics data but with any data so
suppose I need to take the union of
these two sets the first set is integers
0 to 4 99 and 50 1 2 999 and my second
set is the integer minus 20 and then 400
2599 so here's how you would do that
using the enraged int range set class
you import it from PI snip tools
utilities you create an int main set one
way to do that is with this syntax
string commas separate ranges colin's
give the start and stop for each range
the stop is exclusive like it's the
convention in Python here's our second
set and then Python already has asset
class that has all kinds of cool
operators including vertical bar meaning
a set Union so we use that we support
all those and we can print the union of
the two sets and it's does a nice syntax
here it says the union is minus 20 plus
the range one hundred to a thousand
exclusive on the thousand this is a real
set not just the string so we can say is
200 in the set the answer is yes is
minus 19 in the set and the answer's no
we can do more complicated things with
with ranges so this is a real problem we
know say that we know that this range on
the DNA is important is the
transcription range it's something to do
with generating a protein but the actual
parts of the data that really code for
the protein are the green here here and
here and we want to know what's left out
called the exons
and our file format is we get the name
of a chromosome we don't care about that
we get the start and last position of
the coating of the whole transcription
range and then we get a list of the
starts for each of these exons those are
the exons and the last of each of the
exons so you have to do just some kind
of normal parsing parts this on white
space in to the well just as you'd
imagine turn it into a numbers with the
int function the data format the
employees input here gave the last
position but in Python we usually want
to go one past the last position which
in Python we normally call end so we do
that and we can create a new set that is
just the the blue thing we had up there
and it'll say it goes from here to there
we take those two lists of numbers and
kind of do normal Python things to break
them up to split them and now we'll get
a list of the start positions a list of
the end positions they should both be
the same length 3.net assert is okay so
we're okay and just built into Python is
something called izip which if you give
it to lists will return a tuple from the
first position of the two lists than the
second and then the third and it does it
on the fly doesn't have to allocate
memory for a complete double list we can
take that range set we had before and do
set subtraction for the output of Isaac
which is this iteration of tuples and if
we do that it does just what we want it
gives us the two ranges that are left
over after subtracting everything and
it's straightforward if we want it in a
different format to go through the
ranges and print the knots nice print
them out nicely
so in range set is a drop-in replacement
for the built-in set class it does i
honestly believe it does everything it
does that sets does set equality
membership subset superset proper subset
cement symmetric difference efficiently
enumerated things backwards there's a
thing where you can delete a member of a
set by position and get an error if it
doesn't exist or not get an error that's
just normal python and that's supported
here also it has a couple more efficient
functions obviously if you have things
represented internally as ranges of
integers you can find the min and Max
very quickly as I think cows are someone
figured out you can also find the sum of
ranges of integers more efficiently than
actually going through them all so we do
that whoops so we support that important
for genomics the human genome goes up to
about 3 billion positions so that's too
big to fit in a normal int so this all
works with the bigger lungs the larger
instant also supports it's very fast and
super memory efficient anytime you have
rangy sets they do have to be sets of
integers integers are kind of special
because if you not only are they
intervals but they're intervals that you
know when they connect and they don't
have to worry about like on real numbers
whether you're the last little bit is
included or not and after you do all
this you can ask for ranges you can ask
third back as ranges or the length of
ranges and so on and it is all kinds of
nice ways to input the data we saw this
one you can give it a new energy element
3 you can give it a tuple which means go
328 not including 8 you can use Python
slice notation and you can also give
lists or innumerable of any of the
preceding things yeah
so in scan only in computer languages
can only hold integer values up to about
2 billion but in genomics we go into 3
billion just for humans and when it can
imagine going even higher it's whatever
it is forgot what it is i think it's 4
bytes along is twice as many bytes and
it goes I don't know into the trillions
I think it's two billion times 2 billion
asst it's the largest long it's very big
I've used this in non genomics things
where I've gotten reports back and I
want to I've got lines back with numbers
and I wanted to see if anything had
gotten dropped out so I use this to
accumulate all the integers I was
getting back in lines and then asked
what was missing and it can do that with
a simple set subtraction and give it in
a nice range format so it's easy to read
okay on a broader topic let's talk about
I think eight slides on genome-wide
Association studies and in particular a
program for my group called fast limb so
apparently it's almost required by law
for everyone doing a genomics talk to
give this slide which shows that
although this is logarithmic scale on
the left even though computers of memory
and all that has gotten cheaper by
Moore's law every two two and a half
years getting more power for the same
price the cost for sequencing your DNA
is going is dropping much faster and now
it is down below a thousand dollars so
we're before it took what do we say more
than a million dollars to do the first
person's DNA now it's routine for
everyone to get DNA what's interesting
is even though there are four humans
three billion DNA locations for most of
them they're the same for everyone in
the world and because they're the same
we don't really need to measure them
when we're doing these kinds of studies
so we concentrate on trying to only
measure the DNA locations that are known
to vary between people and that's less
than one-tenth of
one percent which means we only have
millions of DNA locations that we need
to measure to find differences
genome-wide Association studies you hear
about them in the news all the time the
general idea is you take a set of
individuals and you have measurements of
some trait do they have heart disease or
not coma or not what's their height and
then a set of these snips the DNA
locations ah maybe a million of them for
each person and we try to find a list of
the DNA locations that seem to be
associated with the trait of interest
making you more or less likely to get
the disease so there's a couple
challenges here the first if we are
testing each DNA location one at a time
we've got a million of them and we're
doing the kind of standard scientific
thing of saying our p-value has to be
greater than 0 point 0 5 that means
we're going to get 25,000 false
associations just false hits so somehow
we have to control for that we're
testing so many different things another
problem if you remember a statistic
every statistic flash you've had said
okay the first thing we're going to do
is assume that all our data is iid
individually independent of each other
so for finding the height of people in
the US we don't take people from just
one region we actually picked people
randomly well this genetic data that's
almost never the case first it's often
very convenient to collect data from
families and you think it would actually
be particularly useful to hit the inside
of families and even if it wasn't for
families their populations human
populations are clumpy and in groups so
in no sense is the data that we do
genetic work on independent are the
cases independent of each other and the
final problem is the datasets grow every
year so the first problem they're kind
of just straight forwards to
sticks for multi test corrections we can
do the second problem instead of using
tools like linear regression and
logistic regression we use a tool called
a linear mixed model a linear like mixed
model says you know we know exactly how
related every pair of people in our data
is because we have their DNA we can just
compute it you just do a big dot product
once we know that there ought to be some
way to factor that out and that's what
linear mixed models can do they
basically take data they factor out the
relatedness and then you can just think
of it as doing a linear regression
variables to dependent variables
independent variables to some dependent
variable the final problem the data sets
growing was a big problem because the
algorithms for doing linear mixed models
work a quadratic went with the square or
the cube in memory and time what are of
rhythm fast limb which we wrote about a
few years ago and nature methods is
linear in the number of DNA locations
and the number of individuals there is a
constant we're working on that constant
it's actually getting better and that
means kind of the straightforward way of
doing linear mixed models goes crazy the
best previous method still grew I think
quadratically with the square and we can
go to numbers of individuals way beyond
5,000 you might need a lot of computer
memory to do this well still linear with
the number of people so we can actually
run fasten on the same data that we've
been playing with so we read that same
data set we've been reading over and
over again we read a phenotype file in
this case it's just the string because
this version of faciem doesn't use my
fino reader yet there's a covariant file
which is things that aren't genetic that
you want to factor out like usually
things like us sex of the person and age
we bring in 10
our ji woz functions and all we do it
looks just looks almost the same as that
linear regression thing we call before
from the standard library so we pass in
snips which is from our bed reader our
phenotype file our covariant file and we
get a result whoops running running
running
and it says the snip with this name has
a p-value of 2 3 times 10 to the minus
23 so that seems pretty good and
likewise a bunch of these other ones
look pretty good one thing I'll just say
in passing is even though we don't use
pandas for our main data processing we
love using pandas for this kind of
output e stuff things that we normally
would have written a text file and then
maybe brought it up into Excel to do
some last-minute things we write it to
pandas format and then do all those kind
of spreadsheet e things inside inside
pandas and this we can look at
graphically there's a kind of chart
common in genome-wide Association
studies so this is all and on the
synthetic data set this is all 5,000
there's a point here for all five
thousand positions along the DNA and the
data that we had and here is the
statistical significance of whether or
not there's an association between that
location and the trait we gave you can
see most of them are down here this is
10 to the minus fifth but therefore that
are higher than 10 to the minus fifth
including one way up there 10 to the
minus twenty third
so fast slim in the past it originally
only worked with bed files but now it
will work with any snip reader in fact
you can also pass it a string and if you
pass it a string it'll say oh this is a
string I'll use the default reader which
is the bed reader and you can pass
things in memory now internally we do
that I ID intersection that case
intersection we do standardization we do
indexing by property we stack things we
use all the features that we saw
demonstrated I have a version but it's
not public yet that uses the phenotype
reader so that makes it easy to swap
dependent independent data instead of
assuming that one is always associated
with a particular file format and I've
got a version that uses the kernel
reader we run on a cluster it was
spending like six minutes before did any
work reading things from a slow file
format or recomputing and i used the
kernel reader to write that fast in pc
format out distribute that to the
cluster and that loads up like in
seconds so i thought i would end the
talk with just a general discussion
about why we use python i'm not really
any more of an expert on this than
anybody else who's been using it for a
while so let me just share my experience
and you can agree or disagree or add
your own comments so two years ago we
had a refereed journal paper basically
rejected because we gave our algorithm
free open-source but it was in c-sharp
instead of Python and the referee just
didn't want to find a Windows machine to
run it on now if we really wanted to we
probably could have gone back to the
editor and said that's unfair but
sometimes when somebody tells you
something unfairly you should listen to
them anyway because the referee did us a
favor by telling us that our audience
was much smaller because we were using
writing our scientific algorithms our
genomic algorithms not in
I thought we switch to python and we're
getting much better uptake on what we on
the things that we produce another
advantage and I think it's the other
part of it is we don't have to write
everything ourselves we wrote our own or
wrapped our own linear regression before
logistic regression cross-validation all
that when we were doing things in the
other language in Python there are
already beautiful toolkits that you
could have learned about in the other
tutorial to do all those things and you
save so much time by not having to write
every library yourself if you need to
rebid files hopefully oh you use my
library and you won't have to do it
yourself there's also all kinds of
auxiliary things testing packages code
coverage testing API documentation auto
generation which use for this library
somebody's already figure out how to do
logging and you can just use the logging
package it's really work that people can
use our tools as components and not just
standalone programs yeah they people did
use our previous programs but they
always would just run it at the command
line with a text file get a text file
out and that would be done they would
never use it as a component in their own
program and that's what we're getting by
using the two-way community that Python
provides so now I'm going to criticize
the language itself but everything else
is secondary to this social phenomena
which is people share things yeah
that's an interesting question in our
community most people were using Python
my personal opinion is that r and python
are very similar to each other ah so I
don't can't really recommend one or
another I think they both have almost
identical feeling of community and
shared libraries and components so don't
you think the real answer though is you
should find out what everybody else in
your community is already doing and just
go with that i should say i i've only
used to our for a few projects I like
Python better than our but that's just
me I'll talk about some of those in a
second so I'm stealing this from a book
but not about programming languages I
think python is a wonderful terrible
language so it's wonderful because it
has these matlab like slicing and
indexing things that we saw hi snip
tools adapt but that works for matrices
and it works great except it's
inconsistent so there's a thing for hds
so for just numpy arrays you can't do
lists of indexes on both on two
dimensions at once so you end up having
to do it on one step and then another
step and you've just doubled your memory
usage for no good reason in hdf5 there's
a way to read rows or columns by indexes
but your indexes have to be you have to
be sorted and if they're not you just
get an error and you probably never even
do that rule until you broke it I like
win exactly numpy will make a copy of
something versus an umpire ray versus
creating a view even the documentation
doesn't tell you you just kind of have
to look and if you try to look it
doesn't even promise that when you look
at those flags features that that will
always tell the truth I think it does
but it doesn't this language doesn't
promise that it does
one of the things I really missed from C
sharp is refactoring is much worse in
Python so in in c-sharp if we started
with just kind of a ad hoc reader thats
a return to dictionary with I IDs and
and an array and then later we decided
to make it into some kind of class we
would just take some part in our code
that generated the reader and replace
the dictionary type with our new class
types a snip reader and then we would
just get compile errors we'd get like 20
compile errors from everybody who used
that reader and we would go to those 20
places and we would fix it and we would
compile again and now we'd get 40 airs
from every place that use those and we'd
fix those and we do that three or four
more times and after that there'll be no
more compile errors and every single
place in our code that used to assume
that our bed format was a dictionary
would now be guaranteed to know it was
using our new fancy class reader in
Python you change your reader to output
something new and you don't get any
compile errors at all everybody's happy
and then you run and you get a runtime
error one and then you fix that one then
you can run again you get another
runtime error and after a while they
become less frequent but you have no
idea that you've ever found the last one
unless you have a hundred percent code
coverage testing all combinations of
types so that's too bad it's wonderful
our old code had to run we were always
using the latest version of C sharp so
it wouldn't run on other versions of
open versions of C sharp with Python I
develop on Windows but most of our users
are probably running it on on lenox and
we know people you run our code on max
too and everything works fine there's a
little bit of terribleness like you're
all happy and then some library uses
deprecated something or removes a method
and then you didn't do anything but your
code doesn't work anymore because
library got updated
this one kills me Python style is stupid
so this is just the coding standards of
Python there's no this is nothing to do
with the language it's um it's sad but
there's a rule that says abbreviations
are okay but you don't have to do it
modules should be generally that's
normally like filename things are
normally a lower case without
underscores but functions are lower case
with underscores suggested but not
required you'll still see Constance with
all caps and all this is to avoid
camelcase these cap words but your class
name should be cap words so I don't know
it's just the way it is hmm i miss good
at it it it i may have forgot to say
this but I didn't say it here ok here it
is a bunch of wonderful things I love
multiple return values i don't know why
in just every language should have them
python is probably the most readable
language i've ever seen and i've worked
in languages like APL which have a
reputation for being the least readable
languages that in existence i see much
less redundancy especially compared to
c++ not having to have header files and
all that stuff i love unlike java or c
sharp you don't have to make everything
an object if it doesn't need to be an
object print hello world is a completely
fine program and why should it be any
more complicated than that if that's all
you want to do on the terrible side
Python is single threaded almost
fundamentally because of the way it's
architected independent of that it seems
yeah i'll have to look weren't that but
ok here's the two problems so we use we
use MKL a library to do our matrix stuff
so when we do our matrix operations
eigen value or matrix multiply all our
processors get used and we're completely
happy I should probably look at the
concurrency to see what it does but I
understand there's a global access lock
that means things aren't
okay i'll have to look at that more so i
know there's going to be another problem
it's going to make it hopeless in C
sharp C sharp got multithreading at the
same time it's libraries were created so
all its libraries are threadsafe Python
even if some people are using a
concurrency package none of us library
writers are writing for concurrency
which means you'll never be able to use
anybody else's code and be sure that
there's not some threading yeah i'll
have to look at that for things like
file right there's often times you just
like to be able to be writing on
multiple threads okay but when you're
doing lots of matrix operations you're
still okay because you can use things
like the numpy MKL library from anaconda
for whatever they're expensive licenses
I like that you can script anything I've
had scripts from python that called C
sharp and powershell and Hadoop that's
just on the window side so I just know
that anything that can be scripted can
be scripted in Python I'm sorry that it
doesn't have true or enforced interfaces
the idea that you say that this is a PI
snip PST reader and you claim you're a
PST reader and if you're not you'll get
an error message at compile time instead
of a runtime error I've had a thing
where someone wrote code for arrays and
we passed in an array and it failed and
it failed because they wrote it for
numpy arrays and I passed in a regular
Python a riot
and things like equality have a
different definition between empire rays
and regular arrays so they're almost the
two data types structures are almost the
same interface but not exactly the same
so to test that you have to all kinds of
basically test all combinations of of
your types there's a flip side to that
though Java is terrible they defined the
stream class and then they closed it so
no one could inherit it so then someone
defines a new stream class and that
one's probably closed so if you want to
make something that people a generic
thing that people read from it won't
work with any of the standard methods
then another in Python if it's got duck
typing right if you make something that
knows all the methods of stream or at
least all the ones that are used it's a
stream likewise what other language even
had the idea that you could create a
whole new array class and have
everything mostly work like numpy array
so that's pretty sweet and snip reader
any of these classes I can't stop you
from making your own version of it and
we enjoy that freedom so unbalanced the
wonderful is much better than the
terrible more than good enough community
makes the difference someday I'd love to
see a language it's like Python and
readability and some of these other
features maybe has type inference
there's some cool stuff going on in C++
where they're doing things where they
make sure if something follows say list
semantics but it doesn't have to inherit
from list that's concepts light so maybe
someday we'll have a language that's
even better but I'm pretty happy where
we are now I also think we can mitigate
some of the terrible by making better
names when we're doing our styling names
of variables and things do more testing
and I think since we need to exploit the
features it has it has this wonderful
slicing and stuff you know if that's
appropriate for your problem use it
don't be afraid to use its cool features
okay we'll finish a little bit early in
conclude then we have questions I guess
in conclusion pie snip tools is open
source it's on github and pi PI snip
readers snip reader is used by at least
three projects only one of which I'm
intimately involved in I'm peripherally
involved with another the I hope we'll
see that the PST reader generalization
we have this matrix data that we don't
read until we need it but we also have
rows and column labels and properties is
a nice way to get the full efficiency of
numpy arrays because they are numpy
arrays when we actually read them versus
some of what you get from pandas which
is you have I row IDs in column IDs and
some properties and you know you don't
lose track of that this row goes with
this person if you work with genomic
data like bed files and phenotype files
please use this I think undeniable you
should use this if you work with other
data of this type it's not genomic data
I hope you'll consider using it even if
you have to do something like make a low
memory random access reader yourself
before you can use the rest of the
infrastructure and I'm available for any
questions